avignon juin 2000 l'un des grands
spécialistes français de la bei marc
edouard collin met en évidence la
relation entre l'utilisation de
pesticides sur les cultures et
l'hécatombe des abeilles observée
partout sur la planète
quatorze ans plus tard à l'inra
d'avignon toujours au muséum national
d'histoire naturelle au cnrs et au
laboratoire de biologie des lignes e et
des grandes cultures de l'université
d'orléans
une étude conjointe met en évidence les
conséquences de cette hécatombe des
abeilles et des insectes pollinisateurs
sauvages sur la vie culturelle même
intensifiées l'agriculture n'est pas
efficace pour les cultures qui dépendent
des pollinisateurs
c'est à dire qu'elles ne permettent pas
d'améliorer les rendements et elle
entraîne une grande variabilité
temporelle des rendements donc une
déstabilisation d'une année sur l'autre
des rendements et c'est le paradoxe
révélés par cette étude qui a porté sur
54 culture différente observée entre
1989 et 2010 intensifiée c'est à dire
utiliser en grande quantité des engrais
chimiques des pesticides et de
l'irrigation non seulement n'augmente
pas la productivité mais même la rend
plus irrégulière pour 75% des espèces
végétales cultivées
parce qu'elles dépendent de la
pollinisation par les insectes c'est le
cas des légumes
donc on a ici des cultures de carottes
choux de carottes qui est une culture
pour laquelle on mange la racine en
réalité donc on pourrait se dire que les
insectes pollinisateurs n'interviennent
pas ils ne sont pas utiles ici pour pour
ces cultures et pourtant c'est quand
même eux qui réalise la pollinisation et
donc ils vont permettre la production de
graines qui vont ensuite pouvoir être ce
n'est pour avoir des cultures de cartes
et c'est le cas bien sûr des arbres
fruitiers qui ici dans cette
exploitation de saint denis en val
profite du maintien des aides tout
autour de ses poiriers de ses pommiers
là est un réservoir de biodiversité et
en particulier pour les insectes
pollinisateurs
car elle fournit le gîte ya beaucoup
d'espèces d'abeilles solitaire qui niche
qui nidifient au sein des haies et elle
apporte aussi ressources le couvert donc
des ressources nutritives du nectar et
du pollen dû à la grande diversité
d'espèces de plantes d'arbres d'arbustes
pour retrouve dans les airs et donc on
va avoir une interaction entre ces
habitats semi naturels et des habitats
cultiver malheureusement
l'intensification agricole
dans la région centre est une figure de
proue a conduit à détruire une grande
partie de ces refuges pour les insectes
pollinisateurs que sont les haies et à
utiliser des pesticides de plus en plus
puissantes dont on connaît désormais le
coût pour les agriculteurs eux mêmes de
la perte de ses alliés naturels de
l'agriculture